Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest is History. This, I'm proud to say, is the podcast that refuses to be bound by format. Sometimes we like to ask the big questions. What are the lessons of history, for instance? And sometimes we like to narrow our focus to a single year, the extraordinary events of 1981.
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的 restis》。我很自豪地说，这是一档拒绝受节目形式束缚的播客。有时我们喜欢探讨一些宏大的问题。例如，历史能给我们什么教训？有时我们又喜欢将焦点缩小到某一个特定的年份，比如 1981 年发生的非同寻常的事件。
And sometimes we want to take you back to your nervous teens waiting to turn over your history exam paper. And today is just such a day. Our question has been asked and answered every June for decades. What are the causes of the First World War? Dominic Sandbrook is with us. And fair to say, I think, Dominic, having talked to you about this, that you have some kind of quite radical views on the subject. Yeah, heretical views. Yes, contrarian, I think, is the word that's always applied to you.
有时我们想带你回到那些神经紧绷的青少年时期，等待着翻开历史考试试卷。今天就是这样的一天。几十年来，每年六月都会有人提出并解答同一个问题：第一次世界大战的起因是什么？多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）和我们在一起。我想，多米尼克，和你谈过之后，可以公正地说，关于这个主题，你有一些非常激进的观点。是的，一些异端邪说的观点。是的，我想“逆势而为”或“特立独行”是人们对你的一贯评价。
But before we get onto those contrarian views of yours, could you, for the benefit of me, who never actually did the First World War for A-level, could you just run down, give us a story. How was it that the world went to war? Golly, that's a very big question. Well, I'll try to do it as quickly as possible. So the beginning of the 20th century, Europe was divided into really two main alliance blocks. So you had Russia and France with sort of Britain semi attached to the Russian and French alliance called the Entente. And then you had the central powers,
但在我们谈论你那些离经叛道的观点之前，为了我这个当年高级水准考试（A-level）根本没选一战的人着想，你能简单梳理一下，讲讲来龙去脉吗？世界究竟是怎么陷入战争的？天哪，这是一个非常宏大的问题。好吧，我会尽量快地讲完。20th世纪初，欧洲实际上被划分成了两大主要的同盟集团。当时有俄罗斯和法国，英国则半即兴地依附于俄法同盟，被称为“协约国”。然后是同盟国，
which were Austria-Hungary, which was the Habsburg Empire, and the newly formed Empire of Germany. And in 1914, in the end of June 1914, the heir to the Austrian throne, the Archduke Franz Ferdinand, as many of our listeners will know, was assassinated in Sarajevo in Bosnia by a Bosnian Serb gunman called Gavrilo Princip. And the Austrians were furious, as you might expect, and they wanted to launch a punitive war against Serbia. So after a bit of faffing around, they did. They'd got the Germans, their friends, to kind of underwrite it, to say they'd support them. So the Austrians attacked Serbia. Russia, which saw itself as the Serbians' protector, objected to this. They declared war on Austria. They mobilized against Austria. The Germans then piled in against Russia, which also
即奥匈帝国（即哈布斯堡王朝）以及新近崛起的德意志帝国。到了1914年，1914年6月底，正如我们许多听众所知，奥地利王位继承人弗朗茨·斐迪南大公（Archduke Franz Ferdinand）在波斯尼亚的萨拉热窝被一名叫加夫里洛·普林西普（Gavro Princip）的波斯尼亚塞尔维亚枪手暗杀。正如你所料，奥地利人怒不可遏，他们想要对塞尔维亚发动一场惩罚性战争。所以在一番拖沓之后，他们确实这么做了。他们拉拢了德国人——他们的朋友——来为之背书，承诺会支持他们。于是奥地利人进攻了塞尔维亚。自视为塞尔维亚保护者的俄罗斯对此表示反对。他们对奥地利宣战，并针对奥地利进行了动员。随后，德国人也加入进来对抗俄国，这同时也
meant piling in against France because France was allied to the Russians. So now you had the two blocs against one another. And then there's a little bit of dithering for a couple of days while everybody wonders what Britain will do, because Britain is friends, very close friends with the French, but not necessarily formally bound to intervene alongside them and there's a bit of a debate in Britain but then everybody's minds are made up because the Germans in order to deal with the French go through neutral Belgium which by treaty they are not allowed to do and under the same treaty Britain feels duty bound to intervene and look after the belgians so over we go across the channel um and as the title of the podcast has it the rest is history brilliant absolutely brilliant
意味着要对抗法国，因为法国是俄国的盟友。现在，两大集团针锋相对。接着，大家观望了两天，犹犹豫豫不知英国会作何反应，因为英国与法国是朋友、非常亲密的朋友，但并不一定有正式义务介入并与他们并肩作战，英国国内也为此进行了一番辩论。但随后，大家的想法都尘埃落定：为了对付法国，德国人穿过了中立国比利时，而根据条约，这是他们绝对不能做的；根据同一条约，英国觉得有责任介入并保护比利时人。于是，我们横渡了英吉利海峡，嗯，正如播客标题所说的那样，其余的就都是历史了。太棒了，简直太棒了。
um okay this is uh we're both british um and i apologize to non-British listeners, but we are going to start with a very Anglo-centric tweet sent to us by Virgo Sam. And she says, following up on the climax of your account there, we, Britain, should have stayed out of World War One. All it did was cause another world war. That is a thesis that's been pushed very heavily by Neil Ferguson, distinguished historian of the First World War, who published as a counterfactual what would have happened had Britain stayed out. So, Dominic, if we had not gone to war, what would have happened? Well, the first thing to say is that could easily have happened, right?
嗯，好的，这是……我们都是英国人，我向非英国听众道歉，但我们要从一个非常以英国为中心的推文开始，这是维尔戈·萨姆（Virgo Sam）发给我们的。她说，接着你们刚才的叙述高潮来看，我们（英国）本来应该置身于第一次世界大战之外的。它所带来的全部结果，就是引发了又一次世界大战。这一论点得到了杰出的一战历史学家尼尔·弗格森（Neil Ferguson）的大力推崇，他曾作为反事实历史，出版过关于“如果英国置身事外会发生什么”的著作。那么，多米尼克，如果我们当时没有参战，会发生什么呢？嗯，首先要说的是，那完全是有可能发生的，对吧？
That we could easily have not gone to war. So right up till really the very beginning of August 1914, the people in the Liberal government at the time, many of them thought we shouldn't get involved. And even, some of them even said, you know, if the Germans go into Belgium, if they only go through the bottom, if they just pass through and they don't make a great fuss and a hullabaloo, we can kind of let them get away with it. Winston Churchill,
我们完全有可能没有卷入战争。所以直到1914年8月初的真正开始之前，当时自由党政府中的人们，许多都认为我们不应该介入。甚至，其中有些人还说，你知道的，如果德国人进入比利时，如果他们只是从南部边缘穿过，如果他们只是路过而没有大惊小怪、大肆喧嚣，我们或许可以对他们睁一只眼闭一只眼。温斯顿·丘吉尔——
who was a great warmonger, said, you know, if they only just pass through Belgium a little bit, then maybe there's not really a cause for war. So we could easily not have done it. And the reason we did it was because people thought it was the least worst option. I mean, that's the case with all these things. People just thought, well, you know what, if we don't do it, if we don't intervene and the Germans win, they'll be the masters of Europe, we'll be isolated, they'll have all the channel ports, we will be sort of squeezed out and we'll lose our empire, which was basically the consideration at the back of people's minds. We can't lose the empire, we can't let the Germans win. Now, as it happened,
他是个狂热的主战分子——曾说过，你知道的，如果他们只是稍微借道一下比利时，那么或许这算不上什么开战的理由。所以我们完全可以不参战的。我们之所以参战，是因为人们认为这是“最不坏”的选择。我的意思是，所有这类事情都是如此。人们只是在想，好吧，你知道吗，如果我们不这么做，如果我们不进行干预，而德国人赢了，他们将成为欧洲的主人，我们将被孤立，他们将拥有所有的海峡港口，我们会被排挤出去，并失去我们的帝国——这基本上是人们内心深处的考量。我们不能失去帝国，我们不能让德国人赢。现在，正如大家所知，
we did lose their empire. We lost it, you know, 50 years later. And, you know, Germany right now is by far the leading economic power in Europe, in continental Europe. And what happened as a result of the First World War? We had to fight a Second World War, as Virgo Sam says. You had the rise of communism in the Soviet Union and the Cold War with all the costs of that involved. You had the terrific costs of the Second World War, the rise of Nazism, the Holocaust, all the rest of it. So we don't know what would have happened if we'd stayed out. But could it seriously have been worse than what did happen? Now, of course, they couldn't have known that at the time, but we know that now. So? Now, of course, they couldn't have known that at the time, but we know that now.
我们确实失去了帝国。我们在（大约）50年后失去了它，而且，你知道的，现在的德国已经是欧洲（欧洲大陆）首屈一指的经济大国。那么第一次世界大战的结果是什么呢？正如维尔戈·萨姆所说，我们不得不打第二次世界大战。苏联共产主义的崛起以及伴随其所有代价的冷战。第二次世界大战的巨大代价、纳粹主义的崛起、大屠杀，以及其他种种。所以我们并不知道如果我们置身事外会发生什么。但它难道真的会比实际发生的事情更糟糕吗？当然，他们当时不可能知道这一点，但我们现在知道了。所以？当然，他们当时不可能知道这一点，但我们现在知道了。
So with the benefit of hindsight, it seems to be obvious that we shouldn't have. If we had stayed out, then presumably Germany would have won. And one of the reasons why Germany would probably have won is that we were kind of, we had agreed with the French that our navy would patrol the channel.
因此，事后诸葛亮地来看，我们当时似乎确实不应该参战。如果我们置身事外，那么德国人大概就会赢。德国人之所以可能会赢的原因之一，是我们当时与法国人达成了一致，即我们的海军将负责巡逻英吉利海峡。
Yes, that's right. The French had no naval presence at all in the channel. That's absolutely right. So we essentially would have sold the French down the line. And the French ambassador famously said that he was waiting to see if the word honour was going to be deleted from the English dictionary while he was waiting for the British to make their mind up. I see a lot of the French thought we wouldn't do it because they thought they're perfidious,
是的，没错。法国人在海峡没有任何海军力量。完全正确。所以我们本质上是把法国人给出卖了。当时法国大使曾有一句名言：他在等待英国人拿定主意时，甚至在琢磨“荣誉”这个词会不会从英文词典里被删掉。我看得出来，很多法国人都认为我们不会参战，因为他们觉得英国人背信弃义，
you know, they're treacherous shits, the British. They probably will sell us out. And a lot of French, you know, are sort of crying and oh woe is me, the Brits, they never, you know, they always let you down basically. And a lot of people abroad, the general assumption abroad was that Britain probably wouldn't get involved. So the Kaiser, for example, who has this huge complex about Britain, because he's the grandson of Queen Victoria, and he thinks his British relatives have always looked down on him. And he has this sort of, this sort of almost tragicomic sense of inadequacy, because, you know, cousin George and Uncle Eddie are always sort of laughing at his German way he thinks
你知道的，英国人就是一群背信弃义的混蛋。他们很可能会把我们出卖。许多法国人，你知道的，都在那儿哭哭啼啼，感慨命运不济，说英国人总是不可靠，你知道的，他们关键时刻总是掉链子。许多国外的人——国外的普遍猜测也是英国大概不会卷入。所以，比如德皇，他对英国有着巨大的情结，因为他是维多利亚女王的孙子，他总觉得自己的英国亲戚一直看不起他。他有一种近乎悲喜剧般的不安全感，因为，你知道的，乔治表弟和埃迪叔叔总是拿他身上的德国习气开玩笑，他心想
the brits you know surely the british will not intervene surely they won't do it and as you say i think um there was a question of honor so for the liberal government at the time they thought you know we've made this pledge to the french we actually can't we'll lose our good name if we don't if we do the dirty on them them. And if we leave them to face the might of basically the most modern professional army in Europe, which was the German army, because the Germans had already wiped the floor with the French in 1870-71. They probably have beaten them again in 1914, and then turned to deal with Russia. So I think it's a plausible assumption that Germany would have won. Right. So this question of whether Britain should have entered the war, and the framing that
英国人，你知道的，英国人肯定不会干预的，他们绝对不会这么做的。正如你所说，我认为，嗯，这其中存在一个荣誉的问题。因此，对于当时的自由党政府来说，他们觉得，你看，我们对法国人作出了承诺，我们其实不能……如果我们对他们不仁不义，如果我们不履行诺言，我们就会名誉扫地。如果我们任由他们去面对欧洲最现代、最职业化的军队——也就是德国军队——的全部兵力（因为德国人在1870-71年已经把法国人打得落花流水），他们很可能会在1914年再次击败法国，然后转过头来对付俄国。因此，我认为德国会获胜是一个合理的推测。没错。所以，关于英国是否应该参战的问题，以及我们当时
we could easily not have done. So ultimately, it comes down to the decision of basically of individual ministers. Yeah. And that really focuses in on the much broader question of are the causes of the First World War sweeping? You know, is it the nature of capitalism? Is it the nature of imperialism? Is it the nature of industrial civilization in Europe? Or is it because the Archduke's car took a wrong turning in Sarajevo? And people have argued both, haven't they? And there's a sense really, in which the fascination, I mean, I would guess that this is the question that has been most discussed, most debated, most disagreed about it. Christopher Clarke in his brilliant book, The Sleepwalkers, says that even
完全可以不参战的这种宏观构架。所以最终，这归结为基本上由个别大臣作出的决定。是的。而这就将焦点集中到一个更广泛的问题上：第一次世界大战的起因是宏大而深远的吗？你知道的，这是资本主义的本质吗？是帝国主义的本质吗？是欧洲工业文明的本质吗？还是因为大公的汽车在萨拉热窝转错了弯？人们对这两种观点都有所争论，不是吗？从某种意义上说，这种着迷……我的意思是，我猜这大概是那个被讨论最多、辩论最多、分歧最大的问题。克里斯托弗·克拉克（Christopher Clark）在其精彩的著作《梦游者》（The Sleepwalkers）中说，甚至
he, who seems to have read everything on the subject, that actually it's impossible because so much has been written about it that no one person could ever read it all. Yeah. The fascination of this topic is that it's like a kind of Rorschach test for someone as a historian. If you emphasise the contingent, then there's plenty to prove that. If you emphasise Marxist or whatever theories, then there's plenty for you there as well. So essentially, the question gives you back your reflection as a historian.
连他这个似乎读过该主题所有文献的人都认为，实际上这根本不可能做到，因为关于它的著述实在太多，以至于没有任何一个人能够全部读完。是的。这个话题的迷人之处在于，它就像是对历史学家的一种罗夏墨迹测验。如果你强调偶然性，那么有充足的证据可以证明这一点；如果你强调马克思主义或其他什么理论，那么那里也有充足的证据供你使用。所以本质上，这个问题会把你自己作为历史学家的倒影反射给你。
It does. Do you think that's fair? I think it does. I think it's very fair, Tom. I think that's a very good point. And I think it's an unanswerable question, isn't it? It's like, why did they... The other big question is,
确实如此。你觉得这公平吗？我认为是的。汤姆，我觉得这非常公平。我认为这是一个很好的观点。而且我认为这是一个无法回答的问题，不是吗？这就像是……另一个重大问题是，
why did the Roman Empire fall? And they're ultimately unanswerable questions. There's no formula that will explain it, because it depends how you would, you know, how you would address the question. But also the weird thing, I think, about this question about the origins of the First World War is, in some ways, it's quite obvious why it started. So it started because the Austrians felt they couldn't tolerate any longer Serbia kind of gnawing away at their southern borders. And they thought the assassination of Franz Ferdinand, which Serbia has probably colluded in or covered up, or there's this sort of murky stuff going on with the government in Belgrade.
罗马帝国为什么会灭亡？这些归根结底都是无法回答的问题。没有任何一个公式可以解释它，因为这取决于你将如何（你知道的）如何看待这个问题。但同样奇怪的是，我认为，关于第一次世界大战起源的这个问题的奇妙之处在于，在某些方面，它为什么爆发其实是显而易见的。它之所以爆发，是因为奥地利人觉得他们再也无法容忍塞尔维亚人不断蚕食他们的南部边境了。他们认为弗朗茨·斐迪南的遇刺是塞尔维亚人可能参与共谋或掩盖的，或者贝尔格莱德政府内部正在发生这种见不得光的事情。
And they thought, we can't tolerate this anymore. We have to act. Now, that's not an unfathomable response. That's actually a perfectly, you know, in the grand sweep of history, it's a perfectly rational way to deal with a threat to your southern border. And the weird thing about the origins of the First World War is we don't have the same debate with every other war. It's just this one because of the death toll,
他们心想，我们再也不能忍受了。我们必须采取行动。现在，这并不是一个不可理喻的反应。事实上，这完全是一个……（你知道的）在历史的长河中，这是应对南部边境威胁的一种完全理性的方式。关于第一次世界大战起源最奇怪的地方在于，我们并没有对其他每一场战争进行同样的辩论。唯独对这一场战争如此，是因为它的死亡人数极其庞大，
because it was so cataclysmic, I think. We obsess over the way that it started as though it's some great mystery. We don't do that with the Napoleonic Wars or the Seven Years' War
因为它具有如此巨大的灾难性，我想。我们总是痴迷于它爆发的方式，仿佛它是一个巨大的谜团。我们在拿破仑战争、七年战争
or the Thirty Years' War. It's perfectly obvious why they started. Wars are not anomalous. They're not aberrant. They're the norm. But isn't it because there'd been a century of peace yeah but well the war happens in the context of you know europe essentially um is at peace the great powers i mean i know you have the prussia doing its stuff and getting sand in people's face but but but by and large there is
或三十年战争中可不会这样。它们为什么爆发是显而易见的。战争并不是反常的现象。它们不是畸形。它们才是常态。但难道不是因为之前曾有过一个世纪的和平吗？是的，但是……战争发生的背景是，（你知道的）欧洲本质上处于和平状态，各大国（我知道普鲁士做了一些事，惹得大家很不愉快，但是，大体上说）并没有
no kind of seismic great power conflict of the order of the Napoleonic Wars until the First World War. And so the question then becomes, what is it that drives all these people? And I think we kind of visualise in our mind people in, you know, hats with feathers and ladies in sweeping dresses and, you know, formal tea on lawns. And we have a kind of sense of this Edwardian world that then just gets detonated.
爆发那种堪比拿破仑战争、直到第一次世界大战才出现的震撼性的大国冲突。所以问题就变成了，究竟是什么在驱动着所有人？我想，我们的脑海里会浮现出这样一幅画面：人们戴着缀有羽毛的帽子，女士们穿着长裙，（你知道的）在草坪上享用着正式的下午茶。我们对这个爱德华时代的世界有一种印象，然后它就被炸毁了。
And it's not just because of the First World War. As you say, it's also because communism overthrows the Tsarist regime. Fascism comes to stamp its place in the heart of Europe's most civilised nation. So it's the sense of all these horrors that follow. Why does it explode? Is it a tinderbox or is it an accident? Well, I think it's obviously not an accident because it could have happened earlier.
而且这不仅仅是因为第一次世界大战。正如你所说，这也是因为共产主义推翻了沙皇政权。法西斯主义开始在欧洲最文明国家的中心烙下它的印记。所以，所有这些随之而来的恐怖感令人震撼。它为什么会爆发？它是一个火药桶，还是一场意外？嗯，我认为这显然不是一场意外，因为它完全可能更早发生。
There were two or three occasions. So, for example, when Austria had annexed Bosnia in 1908, the Russians were in a terrible state about it and there was talk then, could there be war? There were constant clashes between the Germans and the French. So the Germans and the French had bad blood from 1870-71 when Prussia had wiped the floor with France
有过两三次这样的契机。例如，当奥地利在1908年吞并波斯尼亚时，俄国人对此感到极其糟糕，当时就有人议论：会不会爆发战争？德国和法国之间不断发生冲突。所以德法之间自1870-71年普鲁士大败法国、
and the German empire had been unified. And I think I'm right that at that point, opinion in Britain was very pro-Prussian. Yes, it was. Majority opinion in Britain was very pro-Prussian. Yes, it was. Majority opinion in Britain welcomed the humbling of France. Yeah, we changed for an obvious reason. We changed because Germany becomes too successful. So, you know, the French were number one enemies for a long time.
德意志帝国完成统一以来就一直心存芥蒂。我想我没记错的话，当时英国国内的舆论非常亲普鲁士。是的，确实如此。英国的主流舆论非常亲普鲁士。是的，没错。英国的主流舆论对法国的失势感到欢欣鼓舞。是的，我们因为一个显而易见的原因改变了立场。我们改变立场是因为德国变得太成功了。所以，你知道的，法国人曾长期头号敌人。
And in fact, there's a very good example of that, of a man called William Le Quex. And he writes these invasion stories. So fantasies, basically, about Britain being invaded by foreigners. The Battle of Dorking. Exactly, this kind of thing. His most famous one is called The Invasion in 1910,
事实上，有一个非常好的例子，那就是一个叫威廉·勒奎（William Le Quex）的人。他写过这些入侵故事。基本上就是关于英国遭到外国人入侵的幻想作品。《多金之战》（The Battle of Dorking）。没错，就是这类东西。他最著名的一部作品叫作《1910年入侵》，
which was commissioned by the Daily Mail. And the Germans went through town after town and they were specifically designed to be towns with very high Daily Mail circulation. And the Mail did a map. The Daily Mail is famous scaremongering, isn't it? This is outrageous claims, Tom. But it sold a million copies, which tells you how popular it was.
这是《每日邮报》委托创作的。德国人攻陷了一个又一个城镇，而这些城镇是专门挑选的那些《每日邮报》发行量极高的地区。《邮报》还制作了一张地图。《每日邮报》以制造恐慌而闻名，不是吗？汤姆，这些都是耸人听闻的言论。但它卖出了一百万册，这说明它有多受欢迎。
But his first edition of it, which had been written, he based it on an earlier book in which it was the Russians and the French who invaded us. So the reason the villains changed was because Germany had overtaken us, German manufacturers had overtaken us economically, the Germans had tried to compete with us in building a navy and lots of dreadnoughts, the Kaiser had done all his sort of mad posturing
然而，他的第一版小说——它是基于一本更早的书写成的，在那本书中，入侵我们的是俄国人和法国人。所以反派改变的原因是，德国已经超越了我们，德国的制造商在经济上已经超越了我们，德国人曾试图在建造海军和大量无畏舰方面与我们竞争，德皇做出了种种疯狂的虚张声势、
and strutting around and moaning about his relatives. So people had turned against Germany and Germany had become public enemy number one, whereas previously it had been France. I mean, one reason we were allied to France, you could argue, is because the French had declined a bit in the sort of league table of nations. They'd gone from being sort of number one or number two to number three or number four. And they were the obvious people for us to ally with rather than the Germans, which might have been the case earlier on. The Neil Ferguson argument is that we didn't ally with Germany because actually the Germans were too weak. Do you buy that? I think there's a bit of truth in that. So that's slightly allied
趾高气扬的姿态，并不停地抱怨他的亲戚们。所以人们开始反对德国，德国成为了头号公敌，而在此之前，法国才是。我的意思是，我们可以说，我们与法国结盟的一个原因，是因为法国在国家实力排行榜上稍微有些下滑。他们从第一或第二位跌到了第三或第四位。他们是我们理所应当结盟的对象，而不是像早期那样可能选择德国。尼尔·弗格森的观点是，我们之所以没有与德国结盟，实际上是因为德国太弱了。你赞同这种说法吗？我认为这其中有一定道理。所以这与
to the Chris Clark argument, which is that we ally with the Russians in particular because we're frightened of them. So it was a kind of appeasement. Yes. Yeah, we're frightened because of the empire, because Russia can sweep down through Afghanistan into India and everything revolves around keeping India. So, yes.
克里斯托弗·克拉克的观点有些不谋而合，后者认为，我们之所以特别与俄国人结盟，是因为我们害怕他们。所以这是一种绥靖政策。是的。是的，我们因为帝国而感到害怕，因为俄国人可以穿过阿富汗长驱直入印度，而一切都围绕着保罗印度的安全。所以，是的。
So I think you don't understand why Britain enters the First World War unless you understand how obsessed people were with India. India is, you know, classically stereotypically the jewel in the crown if you lose that you lose your status as domination you must keep India and Russia is the big threat to India so the best way to protect yourself against the Russians taking India is not to fight the Russians or make allies against them but to have them on your side and that wasn't such a necessarily a ludicrous calculation but inevitably because the Russians and the Germans are rivals, that means Germany ends up being on the other side of the equation.
因此，如果你不理解人们对印度的痴迷，你就无法理解英国为什么要参加第一次世界大战。正如人们经典地、刻板印象般所说的那样，印度是皇冠上的明珠，如果你失去了它，你就失去了作为世界霸主的地位，你必须保住印度；而俄国正是对印度的巨大威胁。所以，为了防止俄国人夺走印度，最好的办法不是与俄国人开战或结盟来对抗他们，而是把他们拉到我们这边来。这未必是一个多么荒谬的算计，但不可避免地，由于俄国和德国是竞争对手，这就意味着德国最终站在了方程式的另一边。
So it's actually more advantageous to us to ally with the Russians, who we hate, than the Germans, whom we don't, which is a kind of weird. And I'm just going to kind of serve you up a nice juicy half-volley here. Was there any chance, do you think, that Britain might have sided with Germany? And if we had, how would that have affected the calculus? Well, you see, you know perfectly well, Tom, that this is my really... I'm here to serve. This is my really heretical view. You see, I oscillate between thinking that we shouldn't have fought the First World War
因此，与我们讨厌的俄国人结盟，实际上比与我们不讨厌的德国人结盟对我们更有利，这真是一种奇怪的现象。我在这里要抛出一个非常诱人的半高球（让你好发挥）。你认为英国有任何可能站在德国一边吗？如果我们真的站在了德国一边，那会对整个战略格局产生什么影响？你看，汤姆，你很清楚，这就是我真正的……我是来配合你的。这就是我那离经叛道的观点。你看，我在两种想法之间摇摆不定：一种是我们根本不该打第一次世界大战，
or that we definitely should, but on the other side. Attack the French. Yeah, I think we should have attacked the French. Yes. I think the security of the Channel Islands has been much underrated as a priority for Britain. No, I think we should have... You seriously think we should have sided with Germany against France? Well, think how it would work, right?
另一种是我们绝对应该打，但应该站在另一边。攻击法国。是的，我觉得我们应该攻击法国。是的。我认为海峡群岛的安全作为英国的首要任务被严重低估了。不，我认为我们应该……你真的觉得我们应该联合德国去对抗法国吗？好吧，想想这会怎么运作，对吧？
So Germany is the rising power. Germany is the dynamic, modern new force on the world stage. If we had allied ourselves with Germany, which was not impossible, by the way, there were people, Joseph Chamberlain in the late 19th century and then Lord Haldane during the Edwardian period, who were very pro-German and who made, you know, sort of slightly feeble overtures to the Germans about the possibility of an alliance.
德国是新兴强权。德国是世界舞台上充满活力、现代化的崭新力量。如果我们与德国结盟——顺便说一句，这并非不可能，当时确实有一些人，比如19世纪末的约瑟夫·张伯伦（Joseph Chamberlain），以及爱德华时期的霍尔丹勋爵（Lord Haldane），他们非常亲德，并且向德国人（以某种略显软弱的姿态）探询过结盟的可能性。
So imagine we've been allied with Germany and Austria-Hungary. Fighting the Russians is no, you know, is no sort of, you know, nothing to worry about. I mean, the Russians are bad guys. They have a very, the most violent, repressive regime in Europe. The Russian elite hold down their population. You know, it's easy to see how you could make a justification for being against them. Little Belgium, who we always sort of talk about so sentimentally, are running the most rapacious repulsive of all european colonies in africa in the congo serbia is basically a kind of terrorist state and that leaves france and of course the french are our ancestral enemies if we're not anti-french then we are nothing
所以，假设我们当时与德国和奥地利-匈牙利结盟。与俄国作战并不是什么（你知道的）值得担忧的事。我的意思是，俄国人是坏家伙。他们拥有欧洲最暴力、最高压的政权。俄国精英阶层对民众实行残酷统治。（你知道的）你很容易看出，你可以为反对此类政权找到充分的理由。至于小比利时——我们总是带着那种感伤的语气谈论它——却在非洲刚果经营着所有欧洲殖民地中最贪婪、最令人作呕的殖民统治。塞尔维亚基本上是一个恐怖主义国家。这就剩下了法国，当然，法国是我们的世仇。如果我们不反法，那我们就什么都不是了。
so i think you can create a great justification for us being on the side of the central powers germany is in many ways one of the most democratic societies in Europe in the early 20th century. This sort of image that they're basically proto-Nazis is rubbish. German trade unions were the strongest in Europe. The German Social Democratic Party. You know, the Kaiser is just a bit of a... He's Mr Toad. He's not Hitler.
所以我觉得，你可以为我们站在同盟国一边找到极好的正当理由。在20世纪初，德国在许多方面都是欧洲最具民主色彩的社会之一。那种认为他们本质上是准纳粹的形象纯属无稽之谈。德国的工会是欧洲最强大的。德国社会民主党……（你知道的）德皇只是有点……他就像是《柳林风声》里的托德先生（Mr Toad）。他可不是希特勒。
Okay, okay, okay. So the Kaiser, he comes to cows and he wears the wrong yachting shoes and the British royal family laugh at him. And so he goes back and he launches a huge programme of naval building. Have I got that right? Yeah, I think that's an A-level, that's an A-star, isn't it? Yeah, thanks. But the reason Britain doesn't ally with Germany is because the Germans are busy building up their fleet.
好了，好了，好了。所以德皇，他来参加赛船会，却穿错了游艇鞋，英国王室因此嘲笑了他。于是他回去后就发起了一项庞大的海军建造计划。我没说错吧？是的，我想这是一篇A-level拿A星的回答，对吧？是的，谢谢。但英国不与德国结盟的原因是，德国人正忙着扩充他们的舰队。
And that is the way, you know, if the Royal Navy is threatened by a rival European fleet, then it's terrible. I mean, I remember reading Saki's novel When William Came. Yeah. When William Came, which is about the Germans launching a naval attack and winning and occupying Britain. And one of the things expressed in that is that if the Royal Navy gets knocked out, then the sea becomes a kind of prison. Yeah. And don't forget, Britain doesn't really have much of an army.
这就是……（你知道的）如果皇家海军受到欧洲竞争对手舰队的威胁，那将是一场灾难。我的意思是，我记得读过萨基（Saki）的小说《威廉来的时候》（When William Came）。是的。《威廉来的时候》，讲的是德国人发动海军进攻并获胜、占领了英国。其中表达的观点之一就是，如果皇家海军被打垮了，那么海洋就会变成一座监狱。是的。而且别忘了，英国其实并没有多少陆军。
So Britain's army is pitiful compared with everybody else's army. Yes. So that would be very easy and and also if um if we don't have a navy and an occupying power does then that that navy can just starve us if there's any hint of exactly yes so the the paranoia in Britain about the naval race is not in time I mean it's not kind of mad is it it's no it's not completely mad i mean it's basically um your classic we were talking about in an earlier podcast about rising powers and declining powers and britain in the early 20th century i think feels itself to be a declining power we'd fought the boer war in which we'd been close to humiliated um there's a real sense that you know there's that sort of Rudyard Kipling recessional poem for people who know that, sort of the sense of melancholy about our empire,
所以与所有其他国家的军队相比，英国的陆军简直少得可怜。是的。所以这会非常容易，而且，如果……如果我们没有海军，而占领国却有，那么那海军只要稍有风吹草动就能把我们给饿死。完全正确，是的。所以英国对海军竞赛的偏执并不是在当时——我的意思是，这并不是某种疯狂的举动，对吧？不，这并不是完全疯狂，我的意思是，这基本上是……我们之前在播客中谈到过的经典话题，关于新兴强权与衰落强权。我认为20世纪初的英国觉得自己是一个衰落的强权。我们经历过布尔战争，在那场战争中我们几乎颜面尽失，
that our best days are probably behind us. Germany is the coming force. So when they start building battleships, when they build dreadnoughts of their own, people get a real tizzy about it, and not unreasonably. They think, you know, we are a country that relies, we're a trading country, we rely on trade, we rely on imports, and if we don't get them, we're in a terrible mess. OK, Dominic, could you put down your pen? Your time is up. We are going to continue with the examination after a break. But for now, we'll be back in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde.
有一种真切的感受，（你知道的）正如鲁德亚德·基普林（Rudyard Kipling）为那些知道的人所写的《退场诗》（Recessional）中所表现出的那样，对我们的帝国有一种忧郁感，我们的全盛时期可能已经过去了。德国才是正在崛起的力量。所以当他们开始建造战列舰，当他们建造自己的无畏舰时，人们真的陷入了狂热，这并非不合情理。他们会想，你知道的，我们是一个依赖贸易的国家，我们依赖贸易，我们依赖进口，如果我们得不到这些，我们就会陷入可怕的困境。好了，多米尼克，请放下你的笔。时间到。我们将在休息后继续考试。但现在，我们稍事休息，马上回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are discussing what caused the First World War, very modestly.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史的 restis》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，向你展示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、独家加更节目并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的 restis》。我们正在讨论第一次世界大战的起因，真是相当谦逊呢。
We've had about 15 minutes, I think. We'll have another 15 minutes to try and answer that question. Then we'll have done it, surely. Yeah. Okay, so lots of feedback for this question on Twitter. And we have a quote here from Dan Jackson, author of Northumbrians, wonderful book. He says, I think there's a crossover between last week's subject and this,
我们已经聊了大约15分钟了，我想。我们还有另外15分钟来试着回答这个问题。然后我们就彻底搞清楚了，对吧？好吧，关于Twitter上的这个问题，我们收到了很多反馈。这里有一段话摘自《诺森比亚人》（Northumbrians）一书的作者丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）的一部精彩著作，他说，我认为上周的主题和本周的主题之间存在某种交集，
because in August 1914, there was a culture war raging in the UK over Irish home rule. And I know that Dan did his doctorate on that subject. Tellingly, when Franz Ferdinand got shot, Asquith wrote to his wife saying, well, at least we won't have to talk about Ireland for a while. And there's a famous comment by Churchill, wasn't there, in I think 1922, where he talked about how the whole map of Europe had changed with the war. But as the deluge subsides and the waters fall short, we see the dreary steeples of Fermanagh and Tyrone emerging once again. So, I mean, that is an interesting point that actually had the First World War not happened, then there may well have been a civil war, certainly within Ireland and perhaps within Great Britain as well. So interesting. Completely forgotten.
因为在1914年8月，英国正爆发一场关于爱尔兰自治问题的文化战争。我知道丹曾在这个课题上获得过博士学位。意味深长的是，当弗朗茨·斐迪南被枪杀时，阿斯奎思（Asquith）写信给他的妻子说：“嗯，至少我们有一段时间不用谈论爱尔兰了。”丘吉尔也有一句著名的评论，好像是在1922年说的，他谈到战争如何改变了欧洲的整个地图，但随着洪水消退，水落石出，我们再次看到了弗马纳和蒂龙阴沉的尖顶。所以，我的意思是，这是一个有趣的观点：实际上，如果第一次世界大战没有爆发，那么很可能会爆发内战，肯定是在爱尔兰内部，也许在英国本土也是如此。真是有趣。完全被遗忘了。
And actually, you said earlier, you said before the break, you were talking about the sweeping dresses and the straw hats and people in the beaches eating ice cream and all the rest of it. And that's our image of Edwardian Britain, that it's this prelapsarian paradise. Yeah, the Larkin poem. All going to be blown away. And it's completely wrong because actually Britain felt like a country
事实上，你刚才说——你在休息前说过——你谈到了长裙、草帽、人们在海滩上吃冰淇淋以及诸如此类的情景。这就是我们对爱尔兰（爱德华时代）英国的印象，认为它是一个伊甸园般的世外桃源。是的，菲利普·拉金（Larkin）的诗。这一切都将被炸得粉碎。但这完全是错误的，因为实际上英国当时感觉就像是一个
on the brink of civil war about home rule for Ireland. There had been people smuggling guns into Ireland. There had been virtual mutiny in the army. And in fact, one reason that Britain's entry to the First World War was a bit of a shambles is that for the first few weeks after the assassination of Franz Ferdinand, basically the government is just sitting around arguing about Ireland and staring at maps of Tyrone instead of staring at maps of Serbia, which they should have been doing. Am I not right that, is it Erskine Childers who wrote The Riddle of the Sands, which was a kind of invasion scare novel? And didn't he end up kind of gun running for the IRA or something? Have I got that right? Right, exactly. Yes, he did. He smuggled guns into ireland exactly right so he writes so he's actually the link between these two stories he writes um uh the the classics book
因爱尔兰自治问题而处于内战边缘的国家。当时有人往爱尔兰走私武器。军队内部几乎发生了哗变。事实上，英国参战之所以有点手忙脚乱，原因之一就是弗朗茨·斐迪南遇刺后的头几周里，基本上内阁只是坐在一起争论爱尔兰问题，盯着蒂龙（Tyrone）的地图发呆，而不是像他们本该做的那样去盯着塞尔维亚的地图。我没记错吧？写过《沙之谜》（The Riddle of the Sands）——那是一部关于入侵恐慌的小说——的是厄斯金·奇尔德斯（Erskine Childers）吗？他后来是不是为爱尔兰共和军（IRA）走私过武器之类的？我没记错吧？完全正确，是的，他确实这么做了。他把枪支走私到了爱尔兰，千真万确。所以他写了……他实际上就是这两个故事之间的纽带。他写了
about german spies and about the germans plotting to invade britain and then later on he's executed for his role in smuggling guns in for the ira so yeah the the irish issue i mean this that's a funny thing isn't it if If Gavrilo Princip waited for the Archduke outside a cake shop, now if he'd gone into the cake, if he'd, you know, if he'd had a sweet tooth, he'd been distracted, he'd gone in to get a bit of strudel or baklava, I suppose, if it was Sarajevo, the Archduke's car had gone past. Who knows, you know, shots might have rung out in Belfast two weeks later. And now we've been doing this podcast about the Great Civil War of 1914 to 1918 in Ireland. OK, here's another one from Tom Richards.
关于德国间谍以及德国人密谋入侵英国的经典著作，后来他因在为爱尔兰共和军走私武器中的角色而被处决。所以，是的，爱尔兰问题——我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？如果加夫里洛·普林西普在大公的蛋糕店外面等候——现在，如果他走进那家蛋糕店，如果他（你知道的）有点爱吃甜食，他分心了，走进店里去拿一块斯特鲁德尔（strudel）或者果仁蜜饼（baklava，假设那是在萨拉热窝的话），大公的车就这么开了过去。谁知道呢，（你知道的）两周后枪声可能就会在贝尔法斯特响起了。而现在我们可能就在录制一档关于1914年至1918年爱尔兰伟大内战的播客了。好了，这里还有汤姆·理查兹（Tom Richards）的另一个问题。
We're on to Blackadder because I think it's inevitable. Discuss the First World War without talking about Blackadder. In Blackadder Goes Forth, Edmund says, the real reason for the whole thing was that it was too much effort not to have a war. In true school essay style, my question is, to what extent do you think this is or isn't accurate that's a good question it is a good question but i don't think no i don't that's quite right i think the way to think of it is that um for all the different actors the austrians the rrians, the Russians, the Germans, the French, having a war looks like the least worst option. So not having a war is like a very bad option because you'll lose a lot of power and prestige.
我们扯到了《黑爵士》（Blackadder），因为我认为这是不可避免的。讨论一战而不谈《黑爵士》是不可能的。在《黑爵士第四季》（Blackadder Goes Forth）中，埃德蒙（Edmund）说：“整件事的真正原因在于，不打一场仗实在太费劲了。”带着标准的学校作文风格，我的问题是：你认为这种说法在多大程度上是准确的，或者不准确？这是一个好问题。这确实是个好问题，但我不认为……不，我不觉得完全是这样。我认为正确的思考方式是，……对于所有不同的行动者来说——奥地利人、俄国人、德国人、法国人——打仗看起来是“最不坏”的选择。因为不打仗是一个非常糟糕的选择，那样你会失去大量的权力和威望。
And you're, you know, they all feel like a war is coming and that it's in their interest to have it now. There is also a degree of fatalism, isn't i mean so we talked about all this fiction i mean the effect of this must be kind of to anesthetize people to the prospect of it or at least familiarize them with it um yeah i think that's absolutely right the people think there will be a war so the german generals all think there is going to be a war with russia and we should a lot of them think we should have it now. We should have it sooner rather than later
而且，你知道的，他们都觉得战争即将来临，现在开战对他们最有利。这里面也有一种宿命论的成分，不是吗？所以我们讨论了所有这些虚构作品——我的意思是，其影响必然是让人们对战争的前景感到麻木，或者至少让他们对此习以为常。嗯，我觉得这完全正确。人们认为会有一场战争，所以德国将军们都认为将与俄国爆发战争，他们中的许多人认为我们现在就应该打。我们应该当机立断，越早越好，
because Russia is rapidly industrialising, building railways and becoming much more sort of developed and modern. And that basically, if we fight them in 1925, we could lose. We're going to lose. If we fight them now, if we get it over with, this is the time. That's what the Austrians think. They think if we don't fight Serbia now, we'll be in a weaker position when we do fight them.
因为俄国正在迅速工业化、修建铁路，变得越来越发达和现代化。基本上，如果我们到1925年再与他们交战，我们可能会输。我们会输的。如果我们现在就打，早点把这事了结，现在就是时候。这也是奥地利人的想法。他们认为如果我们现在不打塞尔维亚，等以后再打时我们的处境就会更弱。
And all of those, you know, people have sort of striven very hard to find psychological reasons for that. But to me, a very obvious explanation is that's not a weird thing to think. I mean, wars do happen. Wars happen all the time. And isn't it also, but also it's,
所有这些，（你知道的）人们费尽心思去寻找其中的心理原因。但在我看来，一个显而易见的解释是：这种想法并不奇怪。我的意思是，战争确实会发生。战争一直都在发生。难道不是吗？但这不也是……
to what extent is the the image of um mountaineers linked by ropes an accurate one that well the one one person falls off and then another one falls off and then another one falls off i mean you've said that britain could easily not have joined the war but that is a part of what happens isn't it that it's it's easier to kind of just follow the guy who's already fallen into the abyss because you're joined by a rope than to kind of try and cling on. Yeah, I think that's definitely true for Germany. So once Austria was fighting, Germany had to get involved. I think the real, to me, and maybe some people will disagree with this,
用绳子拴在一起的登山者的形象在多大程度上是准确的？一个人摔下去了，接着另一个人也摔下去了，然后又一个人摔下去了……我的意思是，你刚才说过英国完全可以不加入战争，但这也是发生的事情的一部分，不是吗？因为系着同一根绳子，顺着已经掉进深渊的人的方向滑下去，要比试图死死抓住不放更容易一些。是的，我认为这对于德国来说绝对是真实的。所以一旦奥地利开战，德国就不得不卷入。在我看来，对我而言——也许有些人会对此有不同看法，
but to me, the real break moment, the real moment where you think, you didn't have to do that, is Russia. So Russia could have let Austria fight Serbia and not intervened. It wouldn't have been the end of the world for the Russians. They could have just let it go and let it be a little local war. But they felt for reasons of prestige and status and because they were worried about, they had their eyes on Constantinople, which was their long-term goal. They thought, no, we can't let that go. We have to get involved. They actually thought they'd appease the Austrians too often.
但在我看来，真正的转折点，那个让你觉得“你本来不必这么做”的真正时刻，是俄国。所以俄国本可以听任奥地利攻打塞尔维亚而不予干预。这对俄国人来说并非世界末日。他们本可以置之不理，让它成为一场局部的微型战争。但出于威望和地位的考虑，也因为他们担心……他们一直盯着君士坦丁堡，那是他们的长期目标。他们认为，不，我们不能放任不管。我们必须介入。他们甚至觉得他们对奥地利的绥靖政策已经够多了。
Okay, so that touches on two other very popular theories for why the First World War happens. One is Ottoman Empire, sick man of Europe, that it's seen to be in an advanced state of disintegration and the jackals are circling. They want to carve bits off so that's that's a part of it and the other one is um particularly with russia is that it mobilizes and it's such a kind of vast ponderous beast that the moment it's mobilized it becomes impossible
好的，这触及了关于一战爆发原因另外两个非常热门的理论。一个是奥斯曼帝国，即“欧洲病夫”，人们认为它正处于深度瓦解的状态，而鬣狗们正在周围盘旋。他们想割占领土，所以这是其中一部分；另一个是——特别是对于俄国而言——它进行了动员，而且它是一个如此庞大、笨拙的庞然大物，一旦动员起来就无法停下，
to stop and so that's the kind of agp taylor line that it's um you know the railway timetables of europe meant that it couldn't be stopped. I mean, the Ottoman Empire is breaking up. There have been the Balkan Wars in 1912 to 13. So the emergence of places like Albania, people fighting over Macedonia. So yeah, when empires break up, people fight over their remains. And that was always going to happen with the Ottomans.
所以这就是A.J.P.泰勒（A.J.P. Taylor）的观点，即……你知道的，欧洲的铁路时刻表意味着战争无法被阻止。我的意思是，奥斯曼帝国正在解体。1912年至1913年曾爆发过巴尔干战争。所以像阿尔巴尼亚这样的地方出现了，人们在为马其顿争夺不休。所以，是的，当帝国解体时，人们就会争夺它们的遗骸。而这对于奥斯曼帝国来说是迟早要发生的事情。
And as for the railway timetables, I mean, H.AA.P. Taylor who's sort of the Neil Ferguson of his day um pushed the argument a little bit too far for sort of TV effect I think but it's true that when Russia Russia has to mobilize because it's so big so it mobilizes earlier and when they did it you know the Tsar didn't want to sign the order the The Tsar resisted and resisted. And he said to his courtiers, when we do this, it will be very hard to stop it. Because it's that thing, you know, when one person tools up, you've got to do it too. Yeah, but also the time it takes for these powers to mobilize, it's going on while diplomatic efforts are happening.
至于铁路时刻表，我的意思是，A.J.P.泰勒——他可以说是当代的尼尔·弗格森——为了电视效果把这个论点推得稍微过头了一点，我认为。但确实，当俄国……俄国必须进行动员，因为它太大了，所以它动员得更早。当他们这么做时，沙皇并不想签署这道命令。沙皇进行了再三抗拒。他对手下的朝臣说，当我们迈出这一步时，就很难再停下来了。因为就是那种情况，（你知道的）当一个人全副武装时，你也必须这么做。是的，但这些大国进行动员所需的时间，是在外交努力正在进行的同时发生的。
And so the two are kind of pulling at each other. Yeah, you're right. And the classic example of that, Tom, is the telegrams that the Kaiser and the Tsar sent to each other, the Willy-Nicky telegrams, as they're called, where they start off sort of saying, you know, we're great friends, we've always been pals, let's not, you know, let's make sure this doesn't happen i'm going to do my best i hope you're going to do your best and even as they're doing it their generals are putting the machinery into pro into action yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's a kind of shadow that then hangs over the cold war i guess that there's a kind of memory of that and that must be one of the reasons why nuclear war doesn't happen. Yeah, that's, I think you're absolutely right. Everybody knows the Cuban Missile Crisis, for example.
所以这二者有点在互相拉扯。对，你说得对。而这方面的经典例子，汤姆，就是德皇和沙皇互相发出的电报，也就是所谓的威利-尼基电报。他们在一开始说，你知道的，我们是好朋友，我们一直是死党，让我们不要，你知道的，确保这种事不会发生，我会尽我最大的努力，希望你也能尽最大努力。甚至在他们这么做的时候，他们的将军们已经在把战争机器付诸行动了。对，对，对，对，对。这就是那种随后笼罩在冷战之上的阴影，我想，人们对那段历史还有一种记忆，这一定就是核战争没有爆发的原因之一。是的，我想你绝对说得对。比如，每个人都知道古巴导弹危机。
You know, the First World War was very much on people's minds, that we can't... Yeah, I bet. We can't go over the brink as they did. Everything must be so carefully deliberated. Yeah. And I suppose also that was really only two powers, whereas part of the mess of the first world war is it's multiple powers
你知道的，人们对第一次世界大战记忆犹新，我们不能……对，我敢说。我们不能像他们那样走向悬崖边缘。一切都必须经过如此仔细的深思熟虑。对。而且我想这也是因为当时实际上只有两个大国，而第一次世界大战混乱的一部分原因在于它是多国卷入的。
all yeah it makes it more complicated anyway here's here here are two paired tweets i'm going to read them both one is from uh james who says did the first world war cause europe to stop being the center of the world um and chris sparkles um australian here should the australians kiwis and pacific islanders have been in the First World War? So they go together well. Yeah. It's a world war. Does.
对，对，这让情况变得更复杂。无论如何，这里有两条配对的推文，我要把它们都读一下。一条来自詹姆斯，他说：“第一次世界大战是否导致欧洲不再是世界的中心？”嗯，还有克里斯·斯帕克尔斯，一个澳大利亚人，他说：“澳大利亚人、新西兰人和太平洋岛民本该参加第一次世界大战吗？”所以这两条推文搭配得很好。是的。这是一场世界大战。确实如此。
I mean, just as the kind of the the the ropes of alliance pull European powers into war. So also do the the ropes of dominion status and so on pull canada and australia and new zealand and indeed india and other other other colonies and indeed french as well into um fighting in in europe um should they have been in the first world war i mean i mean it had to be they had to be really because they were part of the empire and actually that had happened before so in the seven years war and the napoleonic wars there was never you know there was never a sort of deal that you'll you know you'll stay out of it a thousand miles away and let the powers in europe
我的意思是，正如各种同盟的纽带将欧洲列强拉入战争一样，自治领地位等各种纽带也将加拿大、澳大利亚、新西兰，乃至印度以及其他大大小小的殖民地，当然还有法国，拉入了在欧洲的战斗中。他们本该参加第一次世界大战吗？我的意思是，他们不得不参加，真的，因为他们是帝国的一部分。实际上，这种事以前就发生过。所以在七年战争和拿破仑战争期间，从来没有过那种“你知道的，你待在千里之外袖手旁观，让欧洲的大国”
get on with it i mean the colonies have been dragged into both those i mean anybody who's read the um if you're those patrick o'brien um. I tried and found them unreadable. Oh, Tom, no, no, no. It was all just about rope and stuff. That just washes over you. No one knows what that means. All this stuff about sails. I think it's so boring.
去处理它吧的协议。我的意思是，殖民地都被卷入了这两场战争。任何读过帕特里克·奥布赖恩的小说的人……我试过了，发现它们根本读不下去。哦，汤姆，不，不，不。那里面全都是关于绳索之类的内容。这只会让你感到不知所云。没人知道那是什么意思。全都是关于船帆的东西。我觉得无聊透顶。
But in those books, in those books, often they're taking place, it's about the Napoleonic Wars, for people who don't know, and it's about ships at war. But often they're taking place on the far side of the world, on the other side of South America or something.
但在那些书中，那些书里的故事通常发生在世界的另一端，在南美洲的另一侧什么的，那是关于拿破仑战争的，对于那些不了解的人来说，讲的就是战舰的故事。
So there had been global wars before. I mean, this wasn't the first global war, and not the first war in which colonists had been involved. The 18th century is full of proxy wars and colonists fighting each other in North America and stuff. So it was inevitable. It could never have been otherwise. There is the argument, isn't there,
所以以前也有过全球战争。我的意思是，这并不是第一次全球战争，也不是殖民地人民卷入的第一场战争。18世纪充满了代理人战争，殖民地居民在北美等地互相厮杀。所以这是不可避免的。绝不可能有别的结果。有一种观点，不是吗？
that another cause of the First World War is that the colonial, the European colonial powers are honing their ability to kill in the colonies. Yeah. So in a way, one of, I think one of the great novels about the First World War is actually written in the late 19th century, which is H.G. Wells' War of the Worlds. It's a kind of portrayal of an immensely superior power incinerating London. And at the beginning of the novel, Wells overtly compares what the Martians do to Britain to what the British have
认为第一次世界大战的另一个原因是，欧洲殖民地宗主国正在殖民地磨练他们的杀戮能力。是的。所以从某种意义上说，我认为关于第一次世界大战最伟大的小说之一，实际上写于19世纪末，那就是H·G·威尔斯的《世界大战》。它是对一个极其强大的超级大国将伦敦化为灰烬的某种描绘。在小说开篇，威尔斯公开将火星人对英国所做的事情与英国人对塔斯马尼亚人所做的事情进行了比较。
done to the Tasmanians. Yes, he does. You're right. Aboriginal people in Tasmania who effectively get wiped out. And so there's, I think, I mean, I think clearly the First World War does devastate Europe's financial, economic, cultural, moral power. But there is an argument that it's a kind of, you know, it's the empire striking back, it's the colony striking back, it's a kind of tragic payback for what the colonial powers have been doing in, say, in Africa. I've heard that argument, Tom.
是的，他确实这么做了。你说得对。塔斯马尼亚的土著人实际上被消灭了。所以，我认为，显然第一次世界大战确实摧毁了欧洲的金融、经济、文化和道德力量。但有一种观点认为，这是一种，你知道的，这是帝国的反击，这是殖民地的反击，这是殖民地宗主国在诸如非洲等地所作所为的一种悲剧性报应。我听过这种观点，汤姆。
I sometimes wonder whether that argument is sort of historians of empire just desperately trying to put themselves centre stage. So that would illustrate the argument that it's a Rorschach test, that you find it, you find reflecting that your own interests. It's not like European powers needed to hone their killing techniques in Africa and Asia. I mean, in the Napoleonic Wars and the Crimean War and the Franco-Prussian War, they had proved themselves eminently capable of killing each other on European fields. Yeah. OK. Well, actually, let's go on to another question, because in a sense, this is again about the mirror that literature has held up to the war. And we're back to Blackadder. Has Blackadder distorted our views of World War One?
我有时会想，这种观点是否只是帝国史学家们在拼命地试图让自己成为舞台的中心。这就说明了这样一个观点，即这是一项罗夏墨迹测验，你在其中发现的，其实折射出的是你自己的兴趣。这并不是说欧洲列强需要在非洲和亚洲磨练他们的杀戮技巧。我的意思是，在拿破仑战争、克里米亚战争和普法战争中，他们已经证明了自己完全有能力在欧洲战场上互相屠杀。好吧。实际上，让我们进入下一个问题，因为从某种意义上说，这再次关系到文学为战争所持的一面镜子。我们又回到了《黑爵士》。《黑爵士》是否扭曲了我们对第一次世界大战的看法？
Has it been helpful in our understanding? Not just Blackadder. The First World War poets. Yeah it been helpful in our understanding? Not just Blackadder, the First World War poets, Oh What a Lovely War, all of that, lines led by donkeys, the whole tradition. There's a danger in talking about this that you turn into Michael Gove. Michael Gove basically denounced Blackadder and said that lefty historians like me who thought that we shouldn't have fought
它对我们的理解有帮助吗？不仅仅是《黑爵士》。第一次世界大战的诗人们。是的，它对我们的理解有帮助吗？不仅仅是《黑爵士》，第一次世界大战的诗人们，《多么可爱的战争》，所有这些，被驴子领着雄狮，整个传统。谈论这个有一个危险，那就是你会变成迈克尔·戈夫。迈克尔·戈夫基本上谴责了《黑爵士》，并说像我这样认为我们本不该打
the First World War were merely sort of peddling Richard Curtis's... Did he just say lefty historians like me? Yeah, like me who thought that we shouldn't have fought the First World War when we were sort of peddling Richard Curtis's... Did you just say lefty historians like me? Yeah, like me. Yeah, well, that's what Michael Gove would clearly think. So I think he, I think, Tom, you're enjoying it. I can see on my screen Tom is laughing far too much. Yes, famous left-wing historian Dominic Sambro. Could I just say that I played a key role in that? In what? Getting Michael Gove interested in the First World War because I was on Start the Week with Margaret Macmillan and with Michael Gove.
第一次世界大战的左翼历史学家，只是在兜售理查德·柯蒂斯的……他刚刚是说像我这样的左翼历史学家吗？对，就像我这样认为我们本不该打第一次世界大战的，当时我们正在兜售理查德·柯蒂斯的……你刚刚是说像我这样的左翼历史学家吗？对，就像我这样。好吧，迈克尔·戈夫显然就是这么想的。所以我认为他，汤姆，我看得出来你在享受。我看到我的屏幕上汤姆笑得太厉害了。是的，著名的左翼历史学家多米尼克·桑布鲁克。我能说我在其中起到了关键作用吗？起到了什么作用？让迈克尔·戈夫对第一次世界大战产生兴趣，因为我曾和玛格丽特·麦克米兰以及迈克尔·戈夫一起上过《一周开始》节目。
This really is the podcast that brings you brushes with greatness. And after we'd done it, Margaret was talking more about the First World War and we talked about the revision of Siri. I mentioned Gary Sheffield's biography of General Hague and Michael Gove clearly, this was just before Christmas, clearly went back home and read it. And then after New Year,
这真的是一个能让你与伟人擦肩而过的播客。我们做完节目后，玛格丽特谈到了更多关于第一次世界大战的内容，我们讨论了对西里的修订。我提到了加里·谢菲尔德写的关于黑格将军的传记，迈克尔·戈夫显然——这正好在圣诞节前夕——显然回家去读了这本书。然后过了元旦，
started contributing to the debate on the character and nature of the First World War. So I like to think that I too have played my humble part in the historiography of the First World War. Anyway, yes, sorry, I interrupted you. But it's also the poets, isn't it? It's also Wilfred Owen, Siegfried Sassoon. Everybody does them at GTSC or at least they did. And that sort of image of the war is all mud and blood and misery.
就开始参与到关于第一次世界大战的性格和性质的辩论中了。所以我愿意认为，我也在第一次世界大战的历史编纂中发挥了我微薄的作用。不管怎样，是的，抱歉，我打断了你。但这也是因为诗人们，不是吗？还有威尔弗雷德·欧文，齐格弗里德·萨松。每个人在GCSE考试中都会学到他们，或者至少过去是这样。而那种关于战争的形象全都是泥泞、鲜血和痛苦。
I mean, it's a funny thing about Oh, What a Lovely War. I did Oh, What a Lovely War at school. We did a production of it. And it's this great anti-war play at the end of the 1960s by Joan Joan Littlewood and her theatre workshop and a classic left wing agitprop basically and there's a great story about a group of First World War veterans going to an early performance of Oh What a Lovely War and the story is you know they sat through it there were a lot of songs and the songs are meant to be ironic because they're all going to die but the veterans didn't see it that way at all they sang along very happily with the songs and then afterwards they all went to the bar and they weren't standing around traumatized saying oh i never talked about this all the rest of it they
我的意思是，《多么可爱的战争》是一件有趣的事。我在学校里排演过《多么可爱的战争》。我们制作过它的一个版本。这是琼·利特伍德和她的戏剧工坊在20世纪60年代末创作的一部伟大的反战戏剧，基本上是一部经典的左翼鼓动宣传剧。有一个很好的故事，说是一群第一次世界大战的老兵去观看《多么可爱的战争》早期的一场演出，故事是这样的，你知道的，他们坐在那里看完了演出，里面有很多歌曲，这些歌曲本意是讽刺的，因为他们都要死了，但老兵们根本不这么看。他们非常高兴地跟着歌曲一起唱，然后散场后他们都去了酒吧，他们并没有站在那里受到创伤地说“哦，我从来不谈论这个”或诸如此类的话，
were telling each other anecdotes about people who've had their hand blown off or old johnny who i stood next to me had his head shot off by a german and then we played football with him a week later or you know this kind of thing so the idea that people hated it and a lot of people actually wrote home and said they were enjoying themselves in the war because their life back at home in the factory was so grim but the Wilfred Owen Oh What A Lovely War Blackadder take on it as a disastrous muddy bloody mistake I mean that's basically your take as well isn't it I mean you're saying that that it was such a calamity that we should never have got involved in it. But there is definitely, you know,
他们只是在互相讲一些趣事，比如某人的手被炸飞了，或者我身旁的老约翰被德国人打飞了脑袋，然后一周后我们还用他的脑袋踢足球，或者诸如此类的事情。所以那种人们痛恨战争的想法——许多人实际上写信回家说他们在战争中过得很愉快，因为他们在家里工厂里的生活实在是太悲惨了——但是威尔弗雷德·欧文、《多么可爱的战争》、《黑爵士》将它视为一场灾难性的、泥泞血腥的错误的想法，我的意思是，这基本上也是你的看法，不是吗？我的意思是，你是在说这真是一场灾难，我们根本就不应该卷入其中。但毫无疑问，
there is definitely the kind of revisionist school is that it was a necessary war. Well, I don't think it was a necessary war. I mean, I think that's balderdash, frankly. I know if Gary Sheffield has listened to this, he'll have his head in his hands. But I don't buy that at all. I don't think it was a necessary war.
毫无疑问存在着修正主义学派，认为这是一场必要的战争。好吧，我不认为这是一场必要的战争。我的意思是，坦率地说，我认为那是胡说八道。我知道如果加里·谢菲尔德听到这话，他一定会双手抱头。但我一点也不买账。我不认为这是一场必要的战争。
Top left-wing historian speaks out. The man they cannot gag. I think the Guardian are on the phone right now, actually. I think... Come on, let's have some more of your left-wing nonsense, Dominic. But I don't think it wasn't... It clearly just wasn't all mud, blood and misery. I mean, it just wasn't. So there's lots of aspects mud, blood and misery. I mean, it just wasn't.
顶级左翼历史学家公开发表意见。一个谁也堵不住嘴的男人。《卫报》现在大概正给这儿打电话呢，真的。我想……来吧，多米尼克，再多说点你的左翼谬论吧。但我不认为它不是……它显然不全是泥泞、鲜血和痛苦。我的意思是，它真的不全是。所以战争有很多方面泥泞、鲜血和痛苦。我的意思是，它真的不全是。
So there's lots of aspects to the war. Actually, we haven't talked about the war in Italy, the war in the Middle East, the war in the air. You know, there's much more to it than sort of Baldrick in the trenches, which has been reduced to. OK, well, I just want to stick on this because 50-something Gardner, he's hammering home at this point as well.
所以战争有很多方面。实际上，我们还没有谈到意大利战事、中东战事、空战。你知道的，除了被简化成战壕里的鲍德里克之外，还有更多的内容。好吧，我只想坚持这一点，因为年过半百的加德纳此时也在强调这一点。
If the UK had stayed out, would the First World War have been a rerun of 1871, so the Franco-Prussian War? Given what actually happened, difficult to see how quick German victory would have been a worse outcome for UK. So that's basically what you're saying, isn't it? I mean, what's the worst that happens? We have a big economic competition with the Germans in the 1920s and 30s.
如果英国置身事外，第一次世界大战会成为1871年的重演吗？也就是普法战争的重演？鉴于实际发生的情况，很难看出德国迅速获胜对英国来说会是个更糟的结果。所以这基本上就是你所说的，不是吗？我的意思是，最糟糕的结果会是什么？我们在20世纪20和30年代与德国人展开激烈的经济竞争。
I mean, maybe we even fight a war with them. That's the worst case scenario. But I mean, since we did that anyway... Do we know what the German plans for victory were? They wanted a kind of economic community, didn't they? Well, this is Neil Ferguson's claim. He basically says they want to set up the EU, which I think most people regard as a bit of a stretch.
我的意思是，也许我们甚至会与他们打一仗。这是最坏的情况。但我的意思是，既然我们无论如何都这么做了……我们知道德国对胜利的计划是什么吗？他们想要某种经济共同体，不是吗？好吧，这是尼尔·费尔森的说法。他基本上说他们想建立欧盟，我想大多数人认为这有点牵强。
I think the truth is they went into it without great plans. Then once the war started, they did develop a statement of war aims, which were very punitive. They basically wanted to turn the Low Countries into a kind of German fiefdom. They wanted everybody to be in a German-dominated customs union. What were their plans for France? Well, France would be reduced to a kind of German satellite. And for Britain? So if we'd entered and been defeated, do we know what Germany's plans for Britain were?
我认为事实是，他们在参战时并没有什么宏伟的计划。然后一旦战争爆发，他们确实制定了一套战争目标宣言，这些目标非常具有惩罚性。他们基本上想把低地国家变成某种德国的封地。他们希望所有人都加入一个由德国主导的关税同盟。他们对法国有什么计划？好吧，法国将被降格为某种德国的附庸国。那对英国呢？所以如果我们参战却被打败了，我们知道德国对英国有什么计划吗？
No, I don't think they had clear plans for Britain. Clearly would have given up a lot of the empire. They would have demanded the confiscation of colonies. Whether we would have had to take part in some German economic unions is hard to say. But of course, the truth with all these things is that what resulted at the end of the war was never what anybody had planned. So, I mean, we didn't get exactly the results after the First World War that we thought we would get beforehand because we didn't really have clear plans. People's war plans were always changing. And by 1918-19, the emergence of revolution in Russia
不，我认为他们对英国没有明确的计划。显然会放弃很多帝国。他们会要求没收殖民地。我们是否必须加入某些德国经济同盟，这很难说。但当然，所有这些事情的真相是，战争结束时的结果从来都不是任何人计划好的。所以，我的意思是，第一次世界大战后我们并没有得到我们事先想象的那种结果，因为我们并没有真正明确的计划。人们的战争计划总是在变。到1918-19年，俄国革命的爆发
and the fears of the spread of Bolshevism mean everything has been thrown into confusion. So as a left-wing historian, obviously we should look at the Marxist take on the First World War. And Lenin's view on it was that it was the kind of end times for capitalism and imperialism. Yes, that wasn't a prediction that really worked out. No, and I don't think it's a result of the search for profit and search for markets and all that kind of stuff that's a necessary result of imperialism. I don't think you need to go down the sort of Marxist line
以及对布尔什维克主义蔓延的恐惧，意味着一切都陷入了混乱。所以作为一个左翼历史学家，显然我们应该看看对第一次世界大战的马克思主义看法。列宁对它的看法是，这是资本主义和帝国主义的某种末日。是的，那并不是一个真正实现的预测。不，我不认为这是对利润的追逐、对市场的追逐以及诸如此类的事情的结果，那是帝国主义的必然结果。我认为你没必要沿着马克思主义的路线去走
to explain it to you. I mean, I think it starts for the reason most wars start, which is fear. People always think, I mean, maybe you'll have a different take on this going back to the sort of Persian wars and all that sort of stuff. I don't think wars start generally because of greed or because of hatred or any of those things. I think they generally start because people are afraid and they think that war is the least worst option. Because if you don't choose war, you will be poorer or weaker or, you know, your enemies will attack you. I mean,
来向你解释它。我的意思是，我认为它的开始是因为大多数战争开始的原因，那就是恐惧。人们总是认为——也许你对回到波斯战争之类的事情会有不同的看法。我不认为战争通常是因为贪婪、仇恨或任何这些东西而爆发的。我认为它们通常爆发是因为人们感到害怕，并且他们认为战争是两害相权取其轻的选择。因为如果你不选择战争，你就会变得更穷、更弱，或者你知道的，你的敌人会攻击你。我的意思是，
that's the classic reason that you think they're going to fight you, so you do it first. But I think those are the real reasons. There is also the argument, isn't there, that people quite wanted it, that people were quite excited about it, that people felt that a century of peace had been too long. For some people, that's true of peace had been too long. For some people, that's true. Time for a rematch. I mean, if you ever read this sort of Italian futurist poets, for example, I mean, they were itching for... I know you read them all the time, Tom.
那是你认为他们会与你开战的经典原因，所以你先下手为强。但我认为这些才是真正的原因。还有这样一种观点，不是吗？人们其实挺渴望战争的，人们对战争感到相当兴奋，人们觉得一个世纪的和平已经太久了。对某些人来说，和平确实太久了。是时候来一场复仇赛了。我的意思是，如果你读过诸如意大利未来主义诗人的作品，我的意思是，他们渴望着……我知道你一直在读这些，汤姆。
And in Germany, they were kind of enthusiasts for Nietzsche. Yeah, Rupert Brooke in Britain britain you know said you know will be what is it the line about um swimmers leaping into water and washing away the kind of dirt of ordinary civilized life i mean a lot of people kind of bought that that idea there was this sort of cult of there was a cult of violence i think um although plainly it is also the case that people did did entirely understand what a calamity was going to be. I mean, I guess the famous Edward Grey thing about the lights going out over Europe and we won't even lit again in our lifetime. I mean, that's nothing if not a statement that this is going to be a calamity beyond our imaginings.
而在德国，他们某种程度上是尼采的狂热信徒。是的，英国的鲁珀特·布朗，你知道的，曾说过，那是怎么说的，关于“游泳者跃入水中洗去普通文明生活污垢”的那句台词？我的意思是，很多人某种程度上接受了那种想法，存在着一种崇拜，有一种对暴力的崇拜，我认为……尽管显而易见的情况也是，人们完全理解这将是一场怎样的灾难。我的意思是，我猜爱德华·格雷那句名言说的是欧洲的灯光熄灭了，在我们有生之年再也不会亮起。我的意思是，这无异于一种声明，即这将是一场超乎我们想象的灾难。
So it's kind of strange mix of of jingoism and kind of bleak horror. And actually, everybody who knew anything about it, so all the people who were the policymakers, they all did know how terrible it was going to be. So the German generals, Helmut von Moltke, for example, who was the German sort of chief of staff, he had told the Kaiser a couple of years before, when there is a war, it will be absolutely awful.
所以这是一种奇怪的混合体，既有沙文主义，又有黯淡的恐惧。事实上，任何对它有所了解的人，也就是所有制定政策的人，他们确实都知道这会有多可怕。所以德国将军们，例如担任德国总参谋长的赫尔穆特·冯·毛奇，在几年前就曾对德皇说过，当战争爆发时，将会是绝对可怕的。
And even if we win, we will come out of it exhausted and poorer, and it will be absolutely awful and even if we win we will come out of it exhausted and poorer and it will be incredibly draining and we will be a different country afterwards so they they didn't go into it thinking it was going to be jolly kind of flag waving you know it was it was going to be a sort of um a pageant they didn't think mostly that it was going to be over by christmas either did they that's no that's a myth yeah that is a myth i mean some of the soldiers did some of the ordinary soldiers um but none of the generals really think oh this is going to be easy it's going to be a walk in the park i mean of course they don't you know they're not idiots they look at the there's this sort of image that we have the blackadder image that the people in charge are really foolish and
即使我们赢了，我们走出来时也会精疲力竭、一贫如洗，这绝对会是可怕的，即使我们赢了，我们走出来时也会精疲力竭、一贫如洗，这将是极其消耗体力的，之后我们将成为一个不同的国家。所以他们参战时并不认为这会是一场欢乐的、摇旗呐喊的、你知道的、一场盛会。他们大多也不认为会在圣诞节前结束，不是吗？那是，那是个神话。是的，那是个神话。我的意思是，有些士兵确实这么想，一些普通士兵确实这么想，但没有一个真正的将军会认为“哦，这会很简单，这会是一场轻松的公园散步”。我的意思是，他们当然不会这么想，你知道的，他们不是白痴。他们看着……我们有一种这样的形象，也就是《黑爵士》的形象，即掌权的人非常愚蠢，
it's actually the ordinary people who are really smart and clued up. And I think that's completely wrong. A lot of the, as it were, the ordinary people who went out to fight had no idea where they were going and what they were doing. There's all these stories about peasants in France or in Russia coming in from the fields and they're told, you're at war, you have to go and fight. They don't know who they're fighting for, who they're fighting against.
而实际上普通人才是真正聪明、消息灵通的人。我认为这完全是错误的。许多作为出征作战的普通人，根本不知道他们要去哪里，在做什么。有各种各样的故事讲到法国或俄国的农民从田里走过来，他们被告知：你们在打仗，你们必须去战斗。他们不知道自己在为谁而战，在跟谁作战。
The whole thing is a mystery to them. And the people in charge, the scary thing in some ways, is that they did know what they were doing. They were intelligent, they were well informed, but they did it anyway. They did it anyway. And that could kind of be an epitaph for so much that we've been discussing on this podcast. Point of all history. Today, that is it for today. If you know anyone studying 20th century history, do please send them a link to this podcast and they can listen to left-wing historian Dominic Sandbrook giving his revisionist take
整件事对他们来说都是个谜。而掌权的人——从某些方面来说可怕的地方就在于——他们确实知道自己在做什么。他们很聪明，消息很灵通，但他们还是这么做了。他们还是这么做了。这可以说是对我们在本播客中讨论过的许多事情的一种墓志铭。历史的意义。今天，今天的节目就到这里。如果你认识任何正在研究20世纪历史的人，请务必把这个播客的链接发给他们，他们可以听听左翼历史学家多米尼克·桑布鲁克给出的修正主义看法，
and tell them it'll save them hours of revision. Though there's no guarantee it'll get them a good grade, of course. Thanks for listening. We'll be back next week with The Rest Is History. Goodbye for now. Auf Wiedersehen. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
并告诉他们这会省去他们几个小时的复习时间。当然，这并不能保证他们能得高分。谢谢收听。我们下周将继续播出《历史的剩余部分》。先说再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》。想要收听独家加更节目、提前收听、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。